bonsoir merci merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors c'est vrai
que la régularisation des sans papiers
s'étaient pas nouvelle à laquelle on
pouvait s'attendre en italie il ya
encore quelques mois c'est une surprise
pour vous non c'est pas une surprise
parce que ça répond à des idéologies de
gauche qui effectivement ont été mises
en place aussi au portugal où on dire
aux gars que ils font quelque chose pour
la dignité humaine comme il l'a dit
aussi le président du conseil des
ministres giuseppe compter que vous avez
montré en fait le problème c'est que
bien sûr tout le monde voudrait que les
conditions dans lesquelles elles
migrants la non réguliers travail soit
meilleur mais c'est ne pas cette
régularisation qui va résoudre les
choses
au contraire c'est un vrai appel à une
vraie invitation à enfreindre la loi
parce que les anciens employeurs qui
employer des personnes en noir
en fait tu doives est surtout dénoncé
c'est là que ce n'est pas automatique de
naissance que bien sûr une personne
voudrait après avoir des problèmes avec
la loi parce que on ne sait jamais et
les gouvernements changent les règles
changent aussi
et puis il faut pas oublier que bien sûr
il faut éviter que une personne
quoiqu'il soit son âge sa nationalité
soit obligé de vivre dans des conditions
insalubres mais le gouvernement italien
oublie que il ya beaucoup d'italiens qui
sont dans ces conditions de misère et
qui misère qui était aggravée par le
coran d'un virus donc ça veut dire quoi
que les italiens eux ne voient pas
forcément ces régularisations d'un d'un
bon oeil on va comprendre ça ça a été
une
un argument qui a été utilisée par les
forces de gauche qui soutient l'actuel
gouvernement pour conduire à répondre à
envoyer un message à leur électorat
mais dans la situation actuelle il ya
effectivement beaucoup d'italiens qui
sont contraires et qui qui attend des
mesures pour leur quotidien et aussi des
faut pas oublier beaucoup des droits des
migrants qui sont réguliers et qui donc
on fait tous les choses dans le bon sens
quand ils sont arrivés en italie
alors il ya la régularisation évidemment
c'est une chose c'est un départ il faut
ensuite intégrer un c'est son papier
qu'est ce qui est prévu par la suite
parce qu'on le rappelle cette
régularisation elle a un but économique
c'est pour le secteur agricole qu'est ce
qu'on va faire on suit concept crise
sera passée
c'est une belle question effectivement
après l'urgence la crainte que ces
personnes rue passe dans la dans le noir
dans une zone de non droit et qui se
retrouve comme on dirait en position de
faiblesse vis-à-vis surtout des mafias
et puis il ne faut pas oublier que parmi
ces régularisations en réalité si on
parle seulement de l'aspect du travail
le décret approuvé par le gouvernement
italien parle aussi d'italiens qui était
un mois aux nih travailler au noir donc
c'est assez intéressant de voir que ce
ce décret doit essayer de donner des
réponses aussi à des italiens que depuis
des années on le sait travailler au noir
surtout dans l'agriculture et il
récupère aussi la partie des migrants
mais encore une fois il ne faut pas
oublier qu'ils capitale il y un taux de
chômage est vraiment important qu'il ya
beaucoup de chômeurs qui ont essayé qui
ont voulu se manifester pour aller
travailler dans les champs
surtout dans cette phase qui ne peut non
pas pu le
le faire parce que c'était plus facile
pour le gouvernement en place à répondre
à une partie de l'électorat qui le
soutient à la régulière régularisant
heures temporairement les clandestins
merci matteo jose alberti merci à vous